ارتفعت المبيعات بنسبة 50 في المائة تقريبًا
وسلمت رولز أكثر من 500
سيارة فاخرة أكثر من غيرها في تاريخها.
جميل تمامًا في الواقع ، لقد كان عليك تقريبًا
منحه من يدي لإعادته
إليك ما مدى أهمية تصميم النموذج الأصغر الجديد
المعاد تركيزه
بالنسبة لك ،
أعني أولاً وقبل كل شيء ريتشارد ، شكرًا
لقيادة الشبح الجديد وأعني أن
تعليقاتك هي بالضبط  ما نسمعه من
جميع عملائنا في جميع أنحاء العالم بمجرد
دخولك ، لا ترغب في الخروج بعد الآن
، وكما قلت بحق ، فإن
رولز رويس حقيقي ولكن بالطبع صقلنا بشكل كبير
بالنسبة لنا نموذجًا مهمًا للغاية ، إنه
أمر رائع جدًا  توجه مع kalinin إلى
الأداة الرياضية الخاصة بنا في جميع أنحاء العالم وهذا
يرجع إلى ما ذكرته للتو منذ دقيقة واحدة وهو دقيق
للغاية وأن شبح التصحيح الأسود
الذي كنت تقود فيه هو من الواضح أنه
كلما أسميته تغيير الأنا
للفة  s-royce ، الجانب الأكثر قتامة من
العلامة التجارية أكثر قوة ، يمكنك حتى
استخدام التعبير الإصدار الأكثر ديناميكية
مثل ghost